devant la chocolaterie familiale à
Amiens hier soir Jean-Baptiste trogneux
petit neveu de Brigitte Macron a été
roué de coup les fesses se sont
déroulées en marge d'une mobilisation
contre la réforme des retraites le père
de la victime ma fille à ma queue sur le
lien de parenté avec Brigitte Macron qui
est à l'origine de ses violences quatre
personnes seront présentées à la justice
demain dont un mineur la violence n'a
pas sa place dans la démocratie déclare
ce soir Emmanuel Macron
plus de d'un peu partout il a pris
quatre ou cinq
uberculte il a une ou deux côtes de
cassées au scanner cérébral il y a un
hématome dont on espère ça restera Bénin
on doit sa sauvegarde à l'intervention
d'un voisin et trois de ses fils c'est
qui par rapport au président ce jeune
homme c'est le petit neveu de sa femme
donc de Brigitte Macron c'est son petit
neveu à lui il se présente comme son
oncle Emmanuel Macron
père de ce petit neveu était le frère de
Brigitte Macron
le grand-père de l'homme qui a été
agressé était le frère de Brigitte
Macron c'est le fils de sa sœur
le trentenaire perd de deux enfants et
très choqué sa famille déplorerait déjà
plusieurs attentes et dégradations
ciblées contre leurs différentes
boutiques en raison selon eux de leur
lien avec l'épouse du président de la
République Brigitte Macron a dénoncé
dans un communiqué la lâcheté la bêtise
et la violence je suis en solidarité
totale avec ma famille j'ai à plusieurs
reprises dénoncées cette violence qui ne
peut que mener au pire Macron avait un
frère
on l'appelle Mokhtar voilà
ce frère a un enfant bah c'est ça c'est
le fils de son frère
a un enfant voilà qui lui-même a un
enfant
le petit-fils du frère son petit neveu
il y a une souffrance dans ce pays et
puis à un moment donné on bascule dans
un autre monde
avec d'autres valeurs et d'autres
principes si je fais un point Godwin que
vous allez m'engueuler je veux dire
c'est DSA c'est-à-dire qu'on casse
quelqu'un parce qu'il est quelque chose
alors on va dire sans culotte on va dire
5 mèches non Orange mécanique c'est des
malades mentaux là c'est au nom de la
réforme des retraites la première
ministre devient donc la personnalité
préférée des français derrière quand
même Jean-Jacques Goldman
Omar Sy Kev Adams Games Cyril Hanouna
Eric Zemmour Xavier Dupont de Ligonnès
et cette machine à PANINI Tefal le vrai
mépris c'est de mentir aux gens le vrai
mépris c'est ça j'ai toujours dit aux
françaises et aux Français la vérité ce
que je croyais et avec sincérité porter
ses engagements on peut très bien aller
vers les gens les mépriser nourrir son
propre narcissisme les faire semblant de
les écouter et les prendre par des mois
pour des cons je dis pas que c'est le
président de la République il est comme
ça je dis pas que c'est lui mais je ne
dis pas que c'est lui mais on peut très
bien avoir une revenant que vous ne le
dites pas
le patron de Tesla Twitter Space X
fascine autant qu'il agace et certains
petits malins surf sur son image pour
escroquer le public exemple fin avril
avec un certain Gary Kong entrepreneur
sino-américain pour le lancement de son
nouveau magazine dédié à la communauté
chinoise de New York il organise un
grand dîner de gala et pour attirer les
chinois les plus fortunés de New York il
annonce la présence exceptionnelle dès
le musk en personne
Elon Musk deuxième fortune mondiale qui
monte dans son carrosse dans la cour
d'honneur de Versailles l'image est très
forte qu'est-ce qu'elle vous inspire
certains convives dépensent jusqu'à 30
000 dollars pour obtenir une table à
cette soirée avoir une chance de
rencontrer Elon Musk robe de soirée
smoking champagne et à 21h est annoncé
le clou du spectacle l'arrivée d'Elon
musk sauf que ce n'est pas le patron de
Tesla qui se présente mais un sosie un
mauvais sosie asiatique qui sourit qui
accepte de prendre quelques photos avant
de repartir sans dire un mot et pour
couronner le tout il était accompagné
d'un sosie du dalaï-lamabre
ils ont toutes sortes d'exonérations
fiscales concevable et imaginables et
puis on réduit les services publics on
ne rémunère pas correctement les
personnes qui ont des travaux pénibles à
l'issue des quatre temps chez ta famille
qui a le plus de points va me rejoindre
en finale et ils seront à 5 questions de
gagner je leur souhaite de tout cœur
jusqu'à
100000 euros
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la joie de Killian portée en Trion par
les supporters de l'OM
on a une famille les gars c'est
magnifique voilà
la scène est devenue virale sur les
réseaux des larmes de bonheur après cet
élan de générosité
il a de quoi acheter deux iPhone déjà
une cagnotte improvisée pour ce jeune
garçon il s'est fait voler son portable
juste avant le match il vient de changer
un écouteur sur cet iPhone et après
réparation une fois qu'on a changé
l'écouteur pour un autre neuf le
faceding fonctionne plus on a un message
d'erreur qui apparaît là et pourtant la
nouvelle pièce était bien une pièce de
la marque américaine prise sur un autre
téléphone du même modèle assez plein de
petits trucs comme ça qui vont diriger
les gens vers des des
réparateurs qui sont agréés comme
beaucoup d'enfants qu'il y a des fan de
l'Olympique de Marseille ce dimanche il
est venu du nord de la France en famille
pour assister au match au stade
Vélodrome
double récompense pour lui il repart
avec 500 euros et la victoire de l'OM
contre Angers ers ce soir-là bon à
décompte dans Koh-Lanta il part un mois
il mange du manioc il dorme dans le
sable il y a des scarabées qui pondent
dans leur oreille là comme ça et vous en
une heure vous gagnez comme ceux de
Koh-Lanta
foulards
surtout que j'aime pas pleurer
une même pièce détachée ne pourrait donc
pas être utilisée sur plusieurs
smartphones de même modèle selon
l'association halte à l'obsolescence
programmée la marque à la pomme aurait
mis en place toute une stratégie pour
empêcher la réparation de ses appareils
par des réparateurs non agréés si la
pièce ne correspond pas au numéro de
série de du smartphone
votre smartphone peut s'arrêter du jour
au lendemain c'est dans ce monde là
qu'on vit c'est ça qui est joli là les
jolies couloirs les jolies allées les
jolies voitures les jolies costumes les
jolies sourires c'est ça qui est joli
mais les gens crèvent dans ce monde là
et ce monde là ça va il n'est pas
supportable et puis excusez-moi de
m'énerver